be president and thank you police station for
your intervention according to the
fundamental rights agency of the
european union about 45 to 55 percent
of european women have suffered harassment
at some point in their lives i am going to
tell you a few phrases that are sure to be
familiar to you era  an open secret
he liked to provoke but you have
noticed how he dressed these phrases are
accomplices and seek
to play down behaviors that have their origin in
an unequal society where one party
considers and establishes
power relations over another hence sexual harassment is born
and unfortunately this reality does
not escape from any place or space, not
even from public institutions,
not even from this parliament, we could
put a blindfold on ourselves and think
that it has nothing to do with us and
that it is not necessary to ask any
questions or  On the contrary, we can give
visibility to this situation and try to
put solutions on the table
and the  Parliament has
instruments to respond to this type
of situation but it is clear that they
are not working and that is why we ask in
the resolution that we reinforce it with
external advice to assess
how it can improve and be
really useful for the victims to show
solidarity and be on the side  of the
victims who do not feel ashamed, who are not
afraid of losing their jobs,
who stop feeling guilty for
something for which only the person who
harasses and who attacks is responsible, let us put
in place the necessary instruments
to resolve these situations so that
the  shadow of doubt does not accept on everyone
but falls solely and exclusively
on the harassers neither one more attack on
the dignity of women nor an
complicit silence nor looking the other
way because you are not alone I too
[Applause]